هكذا تحولت حياه الامريكيين بعد عاصفه
القرن التي تسببت بكوارث على نطاق اثنتي
عشره ولايه امريكيه مع انهيار خدمه
الطوارئ في عدد من المناطق بشكل ماساوي
تجمد كل شيء المياه والطرقات شهود عيان
يفيدون بوجود جثث متجمده داخل السيارات
المغموره بالثلوج تاتي مره في العمر وفقه
حاكمه ولايه نيويورك لكن استمرار تساقط
الثلوج وردت الاحوال الجويه يعيقان عمليات
الاغاثه والاخضر عجز طواقم الدفاع المدني
عن الوصول الى ناجين عالقين اما في
منازلهم او على الطرقات
[موسيقى]
وفي المقابل توقف شبه تام في قطاع الخدمات
وشركات الطيران تلغي رحلتها بسبب سوء
احوال الطقس حيث الغت ساوث
2474 رحله وفقا لموقع فلاي تاور لتتبع
حركه الطائرات
الارصاد الجويه الامريكيه اصدرت تقريرا
محدثا يتضمن توقعات بانحار العاصفه
القطبيه وخصوصا في شرق ووسط الولايات
المتحده
وتبدو المناطق التي ضربتها العاصفه اشبه
بساحه حرب سيارات معطله على جانبي الطرقات
بيوت مغموره على ارتفاع مترين بثلوج سكان
نحو تسع ولايات بلا كهرباء او خدمات في
وقت تتعثر فيه جهود الاغاثه بسبب الرياح
وتدني الرؤيا والجليد على الطرق
المشهد الصادم في ولايه نيويورك وتحديدا
بوفالو شوارع خاليه من الماره ومن اي حركه
باستثناء الرياح والثلوج
مباني شبه مهجوره بلا اضاءه بانتظار حصيله
ثقيله على الاغلب مع انحصار العاصفه
القطبيه
[موسيقى]